[Music]
charles is with us in orlando hi charles
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave thanks for taking me on this
morning this afternoon sure question is
regarding my parents my parents back in
the 70s virtues to home
with my uncle so three of them were sole
survivorship
since then my my dad passed in 2010 my
uncle just passed in 2021 now my mom has
rights of survivorship over this house
the problem is
my cousins live in the house and they're
just
giving my mom a hard time about moving
out
and so
i think this is more like a moral
question for my part should should
because the bible says not to
you know not to argue with your within
your families and and to
you know to agree quickly with your
enemies
things like that so my question i have
an influence over my mom
should my mom
pursue the eviction because she just
wants to sell the house
she wants to you know give you know uh
just
just
it's just hard yeah
well you're sweet people you're kind
people and um
when the bible talks about agreeing
quickly or
uh going along there's another scripture
that says uh as so
so far as you are able
to
work along with people i mean there's a
whole there's a less parrot talks about
the verse with the most qualifiers of
anything in the bible but
you know as much as you are able and uh
in this case you may not be able because
you know you can't get along with
someone who refuses to
get along
and so the bible does not require that
we are doormats it just requires that
we're kind when we're
strong there's a difference and so some
strength is needed here how old is your
mom
she's 83. okay
so
what you have here is you have cousins
that are taking advantage of a sweet old
lady
yeah and so your mom doesn't need to
handle this you do
with your mom's with your mom's
permission it's not fair to her at 82
years old at the deal with these
characters and these people are curious
they are not entitled to this house are
they
no you know it was a contract my uncle
did with my mom yeah my dad you know you
couldn't have bought that house without
my mom's and my dad's
assistance and it was left and it was
left with survivor intentionally so your
mother is 100 owner of the house
yeah yeah so regardless of how we got
here boys and girls
mom owns this house a hundred percent
yeah and she has and that does not there
is no obligation
anywhere written or unwritten said or
unsaid that allows you guys to get to
live here for free
all right
so you don't know yeah so you don't so
here's what we're gonna do
okay
you guys are going to start paying rent
and you're going to maintain the
property
or you need to make arrangements to live
somewhere else it's up to you
and i will give you a little time to get
all that done
but um this is ending
yeah and uh you know how much time do
you need i mean let's give them three
months i don't care it's been years
yeah it's been eight months already
since your uncle died it's been over 18
months since my uncle died it's been
eight months since we told him so my mom
said okay we're selling the house and
getting notifications they were paying
rent for almost the whole year last year
oh okay okay i got a different story i'm
sorry no no no i i didn't explain it
correctly sorry but your mom wants to
sell regardless she doesn't want even if
they paid rent yeah she wants to sell
this house and be done with it okay so
they just need to move yes
okay so here's the deal um you know what
i would do is just jump on the phone
with them um
or send them a text if you want and say
listen i've been talking to mom about
this here's what mom says we're gonna do
and i'm giving you just as a cousin as
family um
you know uh what what is this this is
august 15th okay so here's what's going
to happen all right you are going to be
out of the house by september the 15th
30 days from today
if you are not out of the house and it's
not in good condition when you leave
then we're going to have our attorney
evict you
we don't want to do that
please don't make us do that
let's just conduct this business and
let's conduct our affairs with class
and if we can help you in some way we
will let us know how we can help but uh
september the 15th the house needs to be
empty and clean
and if it is neither
we're going to have to take other
actions and i'm not going to
negotiate or argue with you about this
this is a statement of what is going to
happen if you are not gone by september
the 15th the next letter you get will be
from our attorney
so please don't make us go to that
expense and please don't let this go
into the courts it's silly to do that
yeah
and just be kind and firm and this is
what we're this is it's just very
matter-of-fact low-key no drama don't
get into the argument of who shot john
and 14 years ago somebody said the
bedroom is supposed to be pink or
whatever the crap family stuff brings up
right i don't know yes yes sir because
they do they want to go back they want
to circle back around chase their tail
again right
yes sir yeah
so just don't feed into the drama so
what do you think the probability is
that when you call them and say
september 15th to date and i'm gonna
follow that up with an email or a letter
or whatever you want so you'll have it
in writing uh what do you think the
probability is they're gone for you have
to evict them zero that's what i think
because i think they're entitled little
jerks
and i think they have they think they
have a right to something that they
don't have a right to they're ignorant
and so i'm afraid they're about to learn
a lesson
so
go ahead as soon as you make the phone
call because i'm in agreement with you i
think this is what's going to happen go
ahead and find a lawyer
and get the gun loaded so to speak
to where it doesn't take 30 more days
screwing around
all right go ahead and go ahead and
start you know get everything moving to
where on september the 15th the thing's
already in motion
yes sir and whatever whatever notice in
the house in florida
no his house is uh it's a it's up uh
northeast
or northeast what state
uh new york state oh okay yeah uh you
probably got some different laws there
man
so you may have to give me the lawyer
may have to give them a formal 30-day
notice after this it may take you until
after christmas to get them out
right in some states it could be 30 days
but i doubt it in new york state i
suspect you probably got a a process
there that's gonna
make you gag but it's okay just still
just walk through and here's the thing
set the timeline in place and then push
every button on the timeline don't let
the can get kicked by anybody
kick don't know can kicking everybody's
going to go exactly where they have to
go
and uh because these kiddos ain't
leaving unless they unless you make them
this is the ramsay show